eight weeks of rallies for a party eight
weeks old culminating tonight in west
london the biggest yet
three thousand people from dundee to
lincoln to penzance united by brexit
and by this man oh and by the way have
you seen what she's done this afternoon
i mean just when you think she can't
sink any lower
she comes back and surprises us i mean
now
she's surrendered to virtually
everything he may want to talk about
theresa may but today the electoral
commission wants to talk about his
party's funding with a visit to its
headquarters to check its practices
around online donations the only visit
they've made during this campaign
farage accused them of bias and
conspiracy
one hour after gordon brown suggested
that we could be being funded by the
russians i mean it's the usual rubbish
el com said they were coming to see us
today what i can tell you now
is they've spent seven hours in our
offices today i may have found nothing
wrong at all this is a campaign which
has become increasingly personal and
unpleasant culminating in farage being
hit with milk check just
yesterday he blames radical remainers
but he's hardly a man who was held back
himself just a few things that you've
said
in recent past you said that if you can
get the sort of brexit you want your don
car can you pick up a rifle and head to
the front
that was a metaphor excuse me said
during a comedy evening what do we want
when do we want it this could just be
the start of the age of farage this
campaign has reshaped brexit for many
it's now wto brexit or nothing yet what
would it even look like
so with wto what happens to say
pensions and our pensions obligations
what happens do we still not have visa
free travel for example we're going to
have that
well that's that's up to the other
european countries but the answer is yes
of course
but if we have a deal with it this is
not difficult this is not difficult but
we have to sort out the
you with details farage has illuminated
this campaign like no other aided by two
main party leaders absent from the stage
for weeks
he has used this election not only to
entrench brexit but to make it
and british politics in his own image
once more lewis goodall sky news west
london